good evening members
and welcome councilor Beale I'm glad
that you're on the on the menu
um
a generator among Chairman's notices
good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the Council on the 22nd is it
um of um February my name is councilor
Boyce and I'm chairman of modern
District Council Members we are
streaming this meeting live as well as
recording and by being present in the
meeting you're giving your consent to
being recorded during each item please
put your hand up to indicate if you wish
to speak
I will then invite you at the
appropriate time
please note that the YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microphones therefore
can I ask that when invited to speak you
remember to turn on your microphone and
turn it off when finished
please reference a page your paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contribution as
clear and concise
as possible
thank you
agenda item
two
apologies for absence
[Music]
thank you
councilor Fluker
this is where an apologies at the moment
of you put your hand up before I asked
members if there was any other apologies
um
if you've got a point of order
uh you raise that at any time so if I
say a gender item three minutes of the
last meeting
to confirm the minutes of the council
held on uh the 15th December Pages 11 to
20 and the continuation meeting on the
12th of January contained on pages 21 to
28.
seconded
thank you uh councilor fluke our first
encounter the legend
and I had my point of order but I've
still got two questions on the minutes
as well so and I think my point of order
refers to the whole gender chairman and
not just what we're considering now but
this is part four rules of procedure
rule um meetings and business to council
and agendas in particular uh chairman
this Council has agreed that all of its
meetings without exception there will be
in the gender item with regards to the
princess Road campus and I wondered if
you can inform Council why that's not on
this agenda tonight
um I'm not able to do that
um Mr Dodson or Mr Holmes
a city
yeah okay
it's not the
yeah
yeah so uh the report that came to
council last outlined um the progress
that had been made and said that Council
would receive uh further updates as
progress became available so there isn't
further updates to provide and nothing
more than it said in the last uh report
and it did say that Council will receive
reports when there is more information
to update them on and there isn't at the
moment yeah well that doesn't reverse
the decision Mr Liz
um have you any other issues on the
minutes councilor fluka
thank you chairman on page 18 if you
just forgive me a moment
um chairman this is page 18 and it's
minute 457 and it's paragraph one two
three four five six
chairman and chairman first of all
there's uh a
typo in there I believe in in the first
line where it says which stated it was a
level requirement I I I think what was
said was it was a legal legal
requirement
but I'd also question a minute it's
because I did raise a point regarding
whether or not
chairman it was a legal requirement of
members to read reports that went to
planning meetings for example and and
and the minutes correcting so far as
it
the way it's answered where where is the
minute incorrect right so where the
minute is incorrect was was that the the
I'm I'm certain that the management
officer said that there wasn't illegal
uh requirement for members to do that
and in fact he sent me something you're
saying there's an admission
that's not what I said and I've listened
to the tape and it does actually allude
to what I just said but maybe the Clark
I'd like to check that later Mr quelch
is incorrect In His recollection what I
did was I sent him a couple of cases
which although explicitly don't
reference the legal requirement it's
implicit in the propositions in those
cases that members do have I think
that's what I said
thank you well I'll circulate the case
law councilor Lagan
thank you mine's just a couple of points
for accuracy it's on agenda uh some 3B
of the 12th of January 2023 page 26 and
for the Clark's references the single
line after the opening sentence it says
that I'm I declared I'm a member of
Adult Community Learning
um it's slightly incorrectly what I said
is my wife is actually an employee of
Adult Community Learning thanks
uh uh councilor Thompson
I'm sorry councilor Stevens
thank you yes I'm Emma Stevens not Emma
Thompson
that's my mistake
um I think on for age 21 the apologies
for absence have been missed from the
minutes of the Council of the 12th of
January I noted your email and I'm sure
that will be corrected thank you
um uh Council Stan she
thank you
councilor fluka
thanks chairman um this is one that
appears on page 20 chairman
um
and it's item number so I began page 21.
it's uh item number two chairman on that
page and it's the second paragraph
chairman there seems to be another typo
here it says referring to the last
council meeting Council fluke requested
that should the meeting lasted
uh until 10 30 p.m uh obviously that
means last but it concerns me enormously
that somebody is not reading these
minutes before they're they're published
and and the second paragraph's not
correct he goes that goes on to say he
suggested that for the forthcoming
budget meeting that provision be made
for an adjournment I didn't say that I
said we should make provision for the
meeting yeah okay fair enough and I
think that'll be something that'll be
discussed later yeah
um
has anybody else got anything on the
minutes
no right agenda item three I agree
um oh sorry is that agreed minutes agree
and the continuation meeting agreed
thank you
um
Declaration of interests
now I've need to
oh
um
yeah uh
I've got to find the word in
um
to disclose the existence and nature of
any discloseable pecuni interest other
uh
disclosable interests and none
registerable interests relating to items
of business on the agenda having regard
to paragraph nine and appendix beer the
code of conduct for members and members
are also reminded they will be required
to declose any such interest as soon as
they become aware should the need arise
through the meeting uh councilor Channel
thank you thank you chairman it's on
page three and it's to do with uh
item seven chairman under B I believe
and it's actually called titled a gender
item 12 council tax discretionary
discount levels chairman I declare an
interest in as much as due to matters
um sort of at National level where
um
I may be aware of some things regarding
an interest that I may have
um chairman that I will not uh speak at
all to them any debate and I won't be
voting on that chairman could that be
registered thank you thank you councilor
Daryl
yeah thank you um chairman um it's an
opportunity interest but as a member of
Essex County Council I think it's
important to declare because this
Authority does have ongoing contracts
with the County Council thank you
uh right no other interests
um gender item five public
councilor Stan chairman can I ask for
guidance from the management officer
because I don't think I need to declare
but I would actually ask for guidance
and I think Council flemen may be in the
same boat
um cancer Durham obviously does but I
don't so can I have Guidance the same
same thing please management officer
this clubs
uh in fact the the terminology is
different it's good for members to
remember the correct terminology first
of all there are three it's
non-disclosable it's a disclosable
community interest
it's a registrable interest and it's a
non-registerable interest okay those are
the three categories within the code of
conduct in relation to the specific
question chairman
um
you only need to register if you're a
member versus County Council
um or any other local Authority oh you
would register a registerable interest
if there is an item
on the agenda that specifically touches
on your role as a member of Essex County
Council there's no need to declare it if
there's nothing on the agenda you're not
aware of anything if you suddenly become
aware of something on the agenda then
you can declare it then
thank you
um
a gender item five public questions Miss
bird have we Annie
we have no public questions thank you
thank you the gender item six Chairman's
announcements
um
members um I'm sad to report
the death of a past or two past
counselors councilor Archer councilor
John Archer who was has been both
chairman and leader of this Council and
ex-counselor Mrs Helen Elliott
um could you just stand for a few
moments
please
thank you members
um
I
over there
hanging on the counter wall now is the
King's powered to us
after the letter of condolences
um
that I sent
um so I just bring that to your
attention
thank you members
right now members I intend to move
um
Council Stan sorry chairman am I allowed
before perder starts I think this is the
last meeting we were allowed to say
something and I'd like to thank you for
being the chairman for the past year
because if I say it after I'm going to
get accused of electioneering but I
think it's important that I personally
would like to thank you for doing it for
another year yeah don't look down and be
embarrassed I you know I think you
should be congratulated it's been a
challenging year so thank you chairman
[Music]
I'm thinking uh Mrs stamp you might
think different times of I moved the
agenda item uh nine which is the budget
medium-term Financial strategy
um
yeah and
and receive a budget statement from the
leader of the council uh now I think if
I've got this right there is an
alternative budget proposal
so what I'm intending to do
um is
um had the leader speech
which will be seconded
um
have Mr Leslie
say a few words or a lot of words but
not too many I hope and then come to the
leader of the opposition uh councilor
siddle to make a response then I will
ask councilor fluka for his alternative
budget proposal and it will be their my
intention to take it as one debate
uh and uh move on to take the vote at a
suitable time
as members understand that
thank you
Right leader
speak as quick as I can chairman just
give me a minute will you please
thank you to apologize for my cold
right
dear chairman members and officers the
financial year of 2022 3 will be
remembered first and foremost for the
cost of living crisis that the country
has faced like all individuals and
institutions this Council has been
impacted by The increased costs which
put pressure on the Council budget and
will also impact on future years that
has however not stopped the council from
continuing to deliver on the program of
work that I set out in my speech last
year and of which this Council its
members and officers can be rightly
proud I set out in my speech at the
beginning of this Municipal year that
2022-3 would be a year of consolidation
building on the Strategic priorities
which have been embedded with our
recently published commercial strategy
climate action strategy and the emerging
Partnership of one Malden District
developed with a view to bring together
key Partners across the district to
address the Strategic issues around
Health economy and Community safety and
support that affect us all I highlighted
that the focus would be on health and
well-being and quality of life and
building social value we have also
progressed the review of our local
development plan approved a
pre-organization reorganization sorry of
our service delivery directorate to
improve efficiency in the use of
resources and to realign our structure
into a more cohesive operational
approach have also updated our corporate
plan while this was brought forward it
could be delivered so quickly because of
the work officers had already done in
building the evidence base ensuring we
now have a corporate plan based on clear
evidence with clear priorities
underpinned by clear guiding principles
and a Divine golden thread which will
steer the council over coming years and
enable the budget challenges of future
years to be addressed through a clear
process of service planning to match
resources to priorities I will turn to
this theme as it is this evidence-based
strategic prioritization of outcomes and
allocation of resources accordingly that
will enable this Council to navigate the
future successfully not from unevidence
motions rather than sound evidence the
past year has been the successful
development for seeing other successful
development and delivery of the one
Malden District partnership the part
ownership brings together key strategic
Partners across the district
encompassing the public private and
voluntary sectors the partnership has
played a role in the development of the
council's UK shared Prosperity fund
program and has been the focus for
partnership working in addressing the
impact of the cost of living crisis on
Modern District residents the one modern
District Community Services guide has
recently been featured by the local
government Association as National best
practice alongside the Innovative
Storage Center for household essentials
which was developed as a community
resource the community guide provides
key information and support on health
and well-being energy saving tips
uh financial support and Community
groups that can help residents across
the district the work of the partnership
is developing and its emerging plan
includes priorities including health and
well-being focusing on Obesity mental
health and addressing the suicide rate
in the district these issues as embedded
in our corporate plan are vital to the
overall well-being of our communities
and it's just through this partnership
working addressing the wider
determinants of Health such as housing
economic opportunities and Community
safety that we will address many of the
issues and priorities within our
corporate plan partnership working is
enshrined in that document and one
Malden District is our primary
partnership for the district we must
also ensure that our services continue
to be delivered effectively and
complement the wider initiatives and
partnership working this was so clearly
demonstrated this year by the way the
way in which the council took a
coordinated approach to the cost of
living crisis supporting the partnership
actions above with the effective
management of cost of living grants and
support to individuals through our
revenues and benefits team and the great
work they do it is this joined up
thinking and working that will enable
our services to have real impact and
protect the quality of life of our
residents of course this is just one
example and across the board we have
officers working hard to deliver
services and support our residents
whilst this is sometimes challenging I
know our officers strive for excellent
services and work hard whether this is
in the office or remotely Council has
also endorsed the memorandum
understanding for the establishment of
the north ethics Association of councils
this initiative will bring together the
councils across the north half of Essex
to work more closely look at potential
for greater strategic alignment and
coordination on the key challenges we
Face housing climate and economic growth
it will also explore at PACE the
opportunities for shared services to
increase the capacity and resilience of
all the partner organizations the two
partnership examples I have outlined
alongside the service delivery review
and the development of the corporate
plan show the work that has gone in by
offices in this political Administration
over the last year to ensure the council
is building the capacity Partnerships
and processes to enable us to manage the
ongoing pressures that the council will
face as costs continue to increase but
real resources reduced it is so
important that we have in place these
building blocks and I have outlined
as I have Outlanders they will form the
strong foundation on which we can build
the future of Malden District Council
and protect and enhance the quality of
life of our residents the council's new
corporate plan puts quality of life at
the heart of everything we do as a
council our vision is to be a
sustainable Council promoting growth and
investment at every opportunity to
support our communities through
excellent partnership working and to
maintain and improved quality of life
the six priorities for the council will
be supporting our communities enhancing
and connecting our place helping the
economy to thrive smarter finances A
Greener future provide good quality
services as well as setting out within
the document how we will deliver each of
these priorities the whole plan is
underpinned by our ways of working we
are committed to running a local
Authority that puts residents first is a
great place to work providing quality
services whilst working in Partnership
to support communities to deliver this
plan we will build on good practice and
continue to focus on the needs of our
residents make best use of resources
adopt modern and efficient ways of
working be digitally efficient deliver
commercial projects and be commercially
focused strengthen our partnership
working to benefit the district strive
to be modern and Innovative Champion our
core values as they set our Cuts culture
and behaviors and support the welfare of
our staff and councilors as a smaller
local Authority in the county we will
Lobby for infrastructure and state our
case bid for funding be more visible and
promote the good work we do this plan
has been shared with all members over
the past two weeks and whilst its
development was accelerated it is a
clear robust and evidence-based document
that sets out what we will do how we
will do it and how we will measure
success and it also sets out the process
through which we'll allocate our
resources as such it will provide
blueprint for the ongoing success of the
council given its importance from asking
the chairman of the council pleased to
move the approval plan up the agenda for
this Council to be heard immediately
following the budget items so to the
budget itself the budget has been
developed through a Collegiate and
inclusive approach encompassing officers
and members and utilizing the finance
working group strategy and resources
committee and all member budget
briefings before being brought here
today for approval of council as leader
I've ensured that the finance member
working group has included
representatives from across the council
including conservatives Independents and
those members unaligned to groups the
approach taken has been to develop a
balanced budget that protects Services
while also seeking savings and
efficiencies some of these savings
include increased on income from Council
assets increased income from recycling a
reduction in Staffing numbers where
efficiencies have been realized the
council is also using its Reserve to
mean vital services to the public in the
face of cost of living crisis and allow
proper Institute review of budgets next
year investment in public assets is also
included such as a new play equipment
the council tax increase is well below
inflation and equates to an additional
12 per week
it is part of an overall strategy that
the budget avoids rash service cuts and
salami slicing of budgets that
old-fashioned approach is
counterproductive and has no place in
sensible budget making and is unlikely
to be in the public interest this budget
alongside the structural changes agreed
for the service delivery directorate
protect services and builds resilience
of course we will have to make Savings
in future years but for the coming year
we have brought stability and resilience
and put in place those strong
foundations I referred to earlier that
will enable the council to review future
models for delivery and reap the
benefits of partnership working the
introduction of shared services and
overheads maximize the potential for
appropriately outsourced services and
build a cohesive and efficient business
model for the future within the
resources available to facilitate this
approach this budget is underpinned by
the appropriate use of reserves which is
fully justified in the current cost of
living crisis as it utilizes reserves
built up over recent years and which
belong to the local community as well as
the council and which we now project
services for residents in these hard
pressed times we will of course use the
processes and the plans set out already
in this speech to ensure going
sustainably ongoing sustainability for
the council in the future years
with these strong foundations in place
the council is well placed for the
future I referred earlier to the
inclusive encompassing work through
representation on the finance working
group of conservatives Independence and
unaligned likewise the strategy and
resources committee now is not the time
for individual political Point scoring
this budget this time now provides us an
opportunity to show how we can
collaboratively and successfully as a
council in the most challenging of times
deliver support and the best outcomes
for the residents of the Malden District
I thank councilor white the chairman of
strategy and resources committee and Mr
Leslie director of resources and his
team for all their hard work throughout
the budget process chairman I commend
this budget to the council for approval
is that secondary thank you
um right Mr Leslie I think I said next
channel would it be possible to sit down
yes yes please do
all right thank you members um I will
read most of this out so don't feel
you'll be missing anything if you cannot
see the screen I just want to remind
members of the engagement that's taken
place we've had regular updates to us in
our committee monthly meetings of the
finance working group
we've had all member budget briefings in
November and January where members could
ask questions see the budget and follow
up and we've had
um
the budget presented to SNR in January
as well so I don't plan to repeat what
you've had there before
um but I do think it's important just to
give you a layout of actually the
reports that are going so you can see
how they all tie in really and that's
what I'll be focusing on the individual
reports that are presented to you today
okay so at the agenda 9A the capital
investment strategy and the minimum
Revenue provision statement the Kepler's
strategy sets out the capital
expenditure and how it will be funded
and the investment strategy sets out the
forecast level of Investments and
expected return that investment strategy
should be considered in conjunction with
the treasury management strategy which
is a following item as well and finally
the MRP the minimum Revenue provision
statement shows the council has no
borrowing requirement we are required to
have an MRP statement which shows the
council has no underlying Capital
borrowing requirement
um you will see some figures in the MRP
that is due to accounting with embedded
leases it relates to some leases within
the waste area that we have to account
for as an embedded lease but that is not
the borrowing requirement
that that relates to us having to borrow
that's at least an accounting issue so
make you aware of that but in terms of
the appendix 2 appendix a we have new
capital items going forward and their
expenditure there as well but that's all
laid out in the appendix 2.
and then appendix a to that
9B is the treasury management strategy
treasury management is the management of
cash flows borrowing and Investments and
of course the risks associated with
those
uh it includes risk management measures
within that investment limits
um which cover both time sector and
counterparty sector been say for example
building societies and counterparty say
being in individual Building Society so
that's that's a type of risk management
that's in the treasury management
strategy along with create ratings as
well so that we have uh Investments with
credit worthy uh agencies and that's
determined within the strategy
we also have a variety of indicators
within the treasury management strategy
for example the average portfolio credit
score uh and also if we were to
undertake any refinancing
indicators around that not that we need
to do any refinancing
because we do not have the borrowing and
also appendix 2 the treasury management
practices are set out and they're the
ones defined by the treasury management
code so that's set out there at appendix
um two of the report
item 9C read the budget side of it so
there's a variety of appendices
that go along with that so appendix one
is really that high level Revenue
summary
um that you'll see so we've won a very
high high level summary overview that's
appendix one appendix two and three
going to the service level details so a
net service level you can drill down on
the individual details there around
services
appendix 4 deals with the forecast use
of our earmarked reserves and also the
purpose of those reserves so you can see
all those reserves are forecast and why
they're held
um as well appendix 5 are coming to
appendix 5 but that is a section 25
effectively statement so my Assurance
statement around the robustness of
budget and adequacy of reserves I'll
come on to talk about that in a minute
and appendix six is the budget survey
within the budget report itself it sets
out for next year an expected opening
general fund balance of 4.7 million a
contribution from the reserves to
maintain Services of 421 000 or leaving
a closing general fund balance of around
4.3 million forecast at the end of next
year
it's a table at paragraph
3.6.3 which shows the budget changes
from this year to next year so that's
that's a useful
table where you can see the changes and
assumptions built in there
um back to uh the Assurance State and
appendix five uh that really focuses on
the robustness of the estimates within
that and highlights risks and other
factors certainly inflation is a key
risk so that's one that's picked up
within the appendix uh side of it also
it features into the pay award as well
that's another significant risk so
outlined some of those risks within that
I have highlighted business rates income
so there's one area where actually is
potential for for higher income than we
forecast but at this stage without
further information
um
that's not prudent to put any more in so
I think that's one area to actually
where there is a positive that we could
see in the future rather than negative
the last section of the report I think
is a very important one it does discuss
obviously the ongoing use of reserves
and the need to address them in the
future to present them falling below the
minimum level that's recommended within
that Assurance statement and we've
covered some of the actions previously
they're being taken to address that
foreign
D the council tax that's essentially uh
the council tax levels but it covers all
of the precepting authorities precepting
of those ones that
um receive council tax which set their
council tax levels
um it has the statutory against tax
calculation in it uh molten has eight
three a 2.99 increase which equates as
previously been said to around about an
additional 12p a week for the average
Bandy property
um 9e the medium term Financial strategy
is what it says on the tin appendix one
is the medium-term financial strategy
it's a three-year forecast based on
assumptions and the current position
appendix 2 lists some of the growths and
the reasons that they're included within
that area I have just flagged out some
of the figures
um that we talked about before obviously
we can see that increasing gap opening
them up based on a do nothing scenario
and of course some assumptions around
the decline in funding
obviously we're not going to
um
do nothing we're going to address some
of those through the plans revisit some
of the assumptions and work towards
closing that Gap but um that's
work which is ongoing
um appendix a or the medium term
Financial strategy supply of details of
the year-to-year changes as well around
that and I think that's an important one
where you can see what the changes are
some of the assumptions involved around
that as well
um and that's the end of the
presentation
um thank you councilor siddle
thank you chairman
we all know that there's a cost of
living crisis and that like all
organizations and people has put
pressure on us
and has increased the pressure on our
finances
the
leader of the council asked me not to
score political points I'm afraid I
can't do that
I have to really
um one of the interesting things that
she mentioned was about the one Malden
partnership
that's a great initiative unfortunately
it was delayed by a year by the
conservative group because when it first
came to this Council they voted against
it
so we've got this fantastic partnership
now which is in place however that
partnership was delayed and could have
been in place a lot lot sooner
I'm pleased that we were collaborative
in terms of the Council budget and it
going through SNR and the finance
working group and we've agreed the
current finances that's about necessity
because we are our Council of no overall
control so we have to work in that way
I try to work in that way over a year or
so ago with the leader of the council
but I was rebuffed in terms of trying to
ensure that happened
by taking this approach we ensure that
we focus on delivery for our services
and for the immediate future
although the budget has been set by the
committee process and now for Council
but hopefully at times that process has
not been smooth it seemed that those
administering the council and sharing
were at times unclear as to what their
approach might be there was a lot of
contradiction and confusion during that
process I heard people talking at SNR
and then disagreeing with that at the
next Finance working group and then
coming to us now and just and going back
to the other point
it's important to recognize that it is
not a long-term solution and that we
need to ensure our budgets are set
intelligently
and that they deliver for the district
I'm pleased that the leader has quoted
my praise of salami's lighting with no
thought if we do that there'll be no
thought for the impact on the
organization
when the cost cutting exercise or the
transformation as a conservative
Administration caught it took place a
few years ago it was a portrayed as a
way of creating the Financial Security
the council required if that was the
case we would not be looking how in the
next couple of years we need to be
extremely careful with how the council
conducts its finances and services
the exercise spent hundreds of thousands
of pounds on consultants and cut our
staff to the bare minimum
at the same time the tangible benefits
were not clearly established and the
corporate projects were not defined as
part of the ignite project
just as an aspiration
due to covid and the lack of resources
the corporate projects were not
delivered at an early stage so three
years on there's been little tangible
benefit there at the same time there was
000 pounds that has been written off as
benefits that ignite identified but were
never established
we spend a huge amount on redundance
costs where we remove staff and services
which now turns out to be misplaced over
the past year even the conservatives
realized that the ignite structure does
not work and that now the organization
has had to be redesigned in the way that
MDC currently is and the structures on
the council disable how the council
operates we have to have to recruit new
staff so that we are able to function
effectively
as residents know at times because of
the lack of resources we've been able to
meet their needs
I know staff at the council have
endeavored to meet the requirements of
the district and work really hard to do
that that's to meet the service
requirements they've had they have to be
recognized what they've have to do under
very difficult circumstances when they
have been pressurized in terms of
resources
the strategy that had been developed
just before I was elected was a very
corporate wish list which officers
worked hard to mold into strategic
themes
these themes had to be simplified whilst
the independence with a brief time
administering the council as there were
two complex there was no way that all of
them could be implemented
over the past year the cows seem to have
been adrift with no defined strategy
coming from those administering the
council creating a void we now seem to
be filling that void with numerous
motions coming to council with a lot of
these causing extra footwork for
officers when we don't have the
resources therefore exacerbating the
resorting situation at the council
the corporate plan is fantastic that's
come forward however it's been officer
LED it's not being member LED it's not
been the leadership LED it's been led by
the officers in terms of the
infrastructure I find that shocking that
we mention that infrastructure where we
have been so badly let down by the
conservatives at this Council and the
conservatives at Essex County Council
who have not delivered the
infrastructure that this this District
needs
we need to establish how we share our
services as all councils are in a
similar position this has not been
helped by the government over the past
13 years with a reduction of funding to
local authorities no long-term funding
coming from the central government with
no strategic vision from them the
message you currently have is use your
reserves that's what they're there for
well that's really great coming from
central government
we are actually in a much better
position than other authorities despite
certain members in the current
Administration declaring publicly that
we are on the verge of financial
collapse the let's see how the Chris
Leslie has shown tonight that that is
not the case
we need to ensure that in future our
resources are clearly connected to
strategy and that we can deliver and a
measured and sustainable way based on
the record of the conservative the past
few years I have no faith in them
delivering that and I hope that lecturer
can see that as well
and thank you councilor I said well
that's one of the most robust responses
I've I've heard
um
counselor uh Fluker would you like to
move your uh uh alternative budget
motion please
oh all right yes
so I've just circulated the amendment to
the budget chairman first of all
um I've just emailed you all the
amendment the amendments to the budget
you should you should have them on the
system there and Excel now this it's too
weird can I remind you that this Council
has decided a long time ago that we
would be paperless and I've actually uh
I've actually sent them out by email and
chairman first first of all can I pay
tribute to councilor siddle because he
clearly brought forward a budget
statement
um and it's fascinating hearing all the
information from from the leader but a
lot of it I would have expected to hear
in her Leader's speech or whoever does
that whoever does that in a couple of
months time and I'm sure I'm sure that
won't be a toy
um chairman the Amendments I bought for
tonight I've done this for two reasons
one to demonstrate to members and as I
said before chairman that I don't think
anybody's ever done this certain
certainly not during the 12 months that
I've I've been uh 12 years since I've
been on the council but when we're
looking at Cost savings and income
chairman these were and I think members
need to understand this because there's
been much talk about Finance working
groups and subcommittees strategy and
resources and all of these things total
member involvement however
however the savings that were brought
forward through the three appendices
that went to strategy and resources were
and came from
CLT and the senior managers none of them
were driven by members this this was
confirmed in a report that went to SNR
Mrs Leslie has confirmed this to me so
there was no member policy uh with
regards to the savings
um chairman
where I am tonight chairman is is that
quite simply chairman I've brought
forward a series of savings through
amendments
um which I mean I'm not sure if you want
me to go through these one by one
well I'm grateful for councilman
councilor Durham is quick counselor
Darwin is quick to criticize but one of
them is is a reduction in members
allowance he was very keen to take the
vast Chairman's announcement I noticed
it's only been to six out lateings
yes as I described you're you're moving
an alternative budget so then I need to
go through everything then thank you Jim
you you have a five minute slot to put
your motion
and you've already taken about four well
Tema can I can I uh can I ask you to
consider the Constitution Article 5 uh
3C thank you chairman and if you're if
you're going to rule on that then I'd be
more disappointed than anybody else
um chairman so my proposal chairman
brings a cost saving of 637
000 pounds this is against the
projection a projective deficit of 452
000 so my my amendments produce the
surplus of over 600 000. German there is
a homeless you know crisis emergency in
this district and one thing I'd like to
have done chairman if we could have
actually achieved this budget would be
to views past that money uh to put to
support a proposed homeless
infrastructure project and I actually
think that's the type of thing we should
be doing so Kevin that is my if you're
going to cut me off tell me to sit down
and I will but I still would like to go
through something I'm letting you go on
oh thank you very much I'll be quick not
too long just no Kevin I'll just go
through them chairman there's a huge
amount of information to go go through
uh no counselor
everything
you'll see
Kevin I'll be quick but please please be
very quick yes I will Charlie is your
motion seconded because you know I'm
I've said you're moving emotion not not
an amendment I've read the rules there's
nothing to say it comes the amendment to
the budget comes forward as a motion
it's an amendment to the budget the
members can vote for it or not if you if
you want to say now that this is a
motion to cancel then why doesn't it
have to be delivered in a timely way
like Notions to council which brings me
on to another Point chairman and that is
we need to go and visit the rules about
bringing forward amendments we shouldn't
be sitting here tonight with a big pile
of paper we should never cut off time
after the date for motions I'm quite
happy to go through this maybe somebody
will second it somebody maybe they won't
but each Amendment chairman has to be
taken in its own right so we can't vote
for the whole lot because some of this
would have to be done in PNC
uh so chairman you know I look towards
your guidance but I hope you'll be fair
I think I think um uh is it is this
motion seconded to start with
secondly so that second bit
um so now you can have another five
minutes giving a a speech as did the
leader and the opposition leader
although they're allowed 15 minutes but
because I've ruled that you're moving
emotion and not an amendment you only
have five minutes but I'll give you five
minutes from now thanks very much
chairman I'm I will I'm mindful of the
fact that I can't speak
to some of these items chairman in uh
public session
can you stop the clock thank you yep yep
yep
um I'm just being told what what we need
to go into confident confidential my
understanding is is that we have to go
into PNC but only for items amb 7 14 17
and 18 which I'm happy to do yeah and
and whilst I'm I'm speaking to the
advice of the 151 officer I'd like to
thank him for his Support over the last
few days so chairman
um is there a point of order Council
signs
no no
uh I think the the Constitution says
emotion or amendments can come forward
providing them delivered in three days
uh councilor Durham and then yeah thank
you I'll definitely getting web Council
of Lucy because I'm sure we all want to
hear what he has to say but um as is my
understanding that alternative budgets
have to be have agreement of the 151
officer can ask whether this has been
presented to him for his assessment I
mean I'll let him answer but yes thank
you so the the alternative proposals
have come forward
um to myself I have reviewed them and we
have the office of comments
um against them and I think they have to
be taken in context of the comments so
for some of them we have been unable to
give Assurance as to the figures around
that and that's reflected in the
comments of the officers and also
certainly around there's some Capital
items as well and capital items cannot
fund Revenue so they clearly could not
be taken forward as Revenue Service
thank you chairman can we have Clarity
on the process are we allowed to talk on
each Amendment or each thing because I'm
totally confused it's I I'm taking it as
on block as I've said uh well um I'm I'm
afraid that's my rule and I I stated
that at the at the beginning councilor
Stevens
thank you chair I would say that I'm
very confused as well so I'm looking at
something on my screen I've got an A3
pack here I've got an A4 pack here I'm
not a great financier anyway some of the
numbers have become hash signs I I'm I
don't know what I'm looking at
somebody's going to need to walk me
through this otherwise at the end of it
I'll just abstain anyway thank you the
the SNR uh the the budget the leader put
forward has been through as councilman
siddle eloquently said uh several
processes this
has come forward
in secret
under our constitution so the 151
officer has has dealt with it but
members have had no no input or
understanding of it so Council of fluka
cannot in my view
uh uh uh he can he can put it Forward on
block but he he he cannot expect the
council to sit tonight and do six months
of work that has previously been done
uh councilor Durham again thank you
chairman
it is a point of order because uh Mr
Leslie has says that some of these are
are not legal we cannot use Capital to
fund Revenue Etc so if we're taking them
on block this is this budget
hasn't satisfied the 151 that it is uh
that was the indication I got from him
well that then we we can't do we can't
debate it then chairman can we but I
think I think what the I think
councilman fluker's argument and it's
not for me to say what his argument is
because he's quite eloquent in putting
his own argument is that if he goes
through line by line he might get one or
two things through
sorry
no I I know
um would you like to uh
try and encapsulate your
um proposals councilor Fluker well
Gemini otherwise I think I'm going to
have to rule it as not yeah I look
chairman I think that what councilor
Darwin says is quite right and I think
he looks at it from a member's
perspective the same as I do
um I'm sure that it was meant more
passionately than anything else but when
you said secretive uh uh amendments and
the Constitution says they have to
remain confidential uh until we get to
this meeting so there's nothing
secretive about this but I think what
this highlights is is two things that
was possible to make a huge amount of
savings that we didn't identify all of
the savings that have been identified
were led by the officers through three
appendices at strategy and resources
nobody can argue that that's what
happened members did not bring forward
any savings and yes it could be argued
and people say to me well you were at
various meetings and everything else and
some of those meetings I did mention
some of these items and I will be
absolutely honest fair and Frank
chairman that some of these items are
actually lifted from clt's appendices
number two and three which were
discounted some by them and some by
members so chairman there's a bit more
in this than meets the eye but I really
do think and I I'm sure the monitoring
officer's got his ears on but it just
seems to be an issue around the
procedurals or the rules of the
procedure here about the way this
happens clearly it is not right
we can't have a situation I don't think
when you can bring for these amendments
that will last out I mean I've not had
an opportunity to read uh Mr Leslie's
response but I I I I I
respect him as the it's the officer's
comments you know I respect him as the
151 officer and I think he's to be
commended on the way that this budget
has gone come through but you know I I
thought I was bringing forward chairman
1819 amendments to the budget
individually it was never meant that
they should be it was never meant that
they should be looked at individually I
mean I'm more than happy to do that and
if you want to take the council in into
PNC I'll I'll speak to the items that
are private and confidential I think I
think
um uh Council I I've got to rule that
you're you're well chairman before you
do that chairman before you do that can
I just say to you then chairman I think
that based on on the governance that
that surrounds this uh I will say
chairman as a compromise that the 151
officer considers these amendments when
the uh in in the uh after we've agreed
the budget tonight uh and it goes off to
one of these lovely working groups to be
considered chairman and if it helps you
determine I'll withdraw the amendments
in the best interest to council
that we feel happy helpful members
agreements we've got we've got the
debate uh on on the budget proposals are
there any questions or comments
budget
[Music]
counselor Darren well chairman thank you
very much I think we're just getting
back on track now aren't we
um
congratulations to to
um the leader the leader of the
opposition and the officers for working
together because there has been
collaborative working to get a balanced
budget as the law dictates
but I'm not really worried about this
year's budget chairman
I'm worried about the ever increasing
Gap
that is going to be facing us
we have
seen today another
District effect Borough Council
effectively going bankrupt woking
today with debts of 2.2 billion pounds
2.2 billion pounds just out of Interest
they have a 62 million pounds a year in
interest repayments
and their their council tax receipts are
39 million but anyway and we are still
debt free and we are debt free but
chairman there is that there is the
problem because
we have to fill those future gaps
if we don't want to borrow to invest and
we know the pitfalls of that
the government want us to use our
reserves they've actually said that the
council should be using their reserves
to provide resident services
but we're a small Authority with small
reserves that isn't hasn't he's not
long-term sustainable
so what do we do how do we close this
Gap
we unfortunately have to cut our costs
we have to cut the costs and I'm afraid
cutting the cost cut it yeah
with the cost cutting is going to mean
service Cuts this morning I happen to
bump into Gavin Jones who you were now
as chief executive of Essex County
Council he was the commissioner for
Slough the commissioner for thurrock
he's the one that told me about woking
and I said goodness me Gavin what you
know why what is happening because there
are lots more councils in that position
and he said to me fundamentally
fundament there are lots of reasons but
fundamentally it's because the members
in those authorities
failed to recognize or failed to
undertake the costs that they needed to
the cuts they needed to bring forward in
order to balance their budget they had
too many precious projects
and they didn't take the cuts when they
were necessary as I said there are lots
of other reasons why but fundamentally
that was the issue another issue was
actually a disconnect between the
members and the officers that is the
reason why we have woking thorough
Slough Croydon and probably a half a
dozen more authorities this year getting
into a financial situation so I'm really
concerned and it's an appeal to the next
members in this chamber in actual fact
again I have to sit down and look long
and hard at their costs and we are gonna
have to make Cuts we are going to have
to be realistic
because I don't think anybody here is
going to Advocate advocate
taking out big loans to get that
commercial property or commercial
projects because we've seen what's that
what that's going to deliver we haven't
got the low hanging fruit we went
through transformation
there isn't there isn't anywhere else to
go so it's a warning chairman that times
are very tough and we're going to have
to take very tough very brave decisions
as members in the coming years thank you
councilor Swain then councilor stamp can
I just add Tim I just update them and
and some of councilor flukers cost
cutting ideas May well be necessary in
the future and we are going to have we
are gonna have to look at things as
dramatic as he is suggesting
I uh I I tend to agree
um to be a counselor sometimes you need
to take hard decisions and if you
haven't got the bottle to do that then
you shouldn't be sitting in a council
chamber
yes thank you chairman
um first of all uh looking through these
um I see that most of them with not all
of them have come up at the finance
working group in S and R and they were
looked at and scrutinized by members so
it's not right to say this is entirely
officer's ideas members looked at these
and said yes we we agree with that we
don't agree with that
um but secondly
um uh with regard to council's Arms
comment yes we some big decisions are
going to have to be made to in order to
restore the situation for the year after
next
but that is to say after this budget
year that Mr Leslie is putting forward
um and the years after that and
um uh work is being done I mean the
corporate plan would have to be refined
to actually provide the meaning
um for uh implications for services and
expenditure uh Mr Leslie has been doing
a lot of work on trying to evaluate what
uh we have to do and what we could
choose not to do
um but given where we are and now we're
just with May coming up these are
matters the new Council will have to
um take up including looking at the
individual items that Council of Luca
has itemized here and which have come up
with SNR before
um but I mean we can't sort of unpick
the budget piecemeal like this so I
would I would um I would move that the
the motion we put to approve the budget
okay
it's a stent in councilor Lagan and
I actually do doing we should be
starting with a balanced budget yes I
totally agree that we've had all these
Finance meetings and we've done
everything by the book but I think we've
all attended meetings up and down the
country whether we're in person or on
Zoom with other Council and other
Council leaders and I think it's really
important we're starting off with how
much are we losing this year 600 Smith
thousand deficit and then it goes on to
to whatever kind of my body is it goes
on to a few couple of million and I I
think we really we were the ones who
asked for the the the the services to
the services that we need to provide and
the ones that I call a luxury months ago
and I welcome councilor uh not counselor
Mr Leslie that he's actually looking at
that now but that should I know sorry
chairman I'm really tired I do apologize
chairman
um and but the thing is we we should
have been doing that before this budget
has been announced and yes I do agree
that we are starting to work together
but it's taking a hell of a long time
and it and it we have wasted a lot of
time on Commercial projects look at
Princess Road how long has that been on
the in the pipeline to be looked at
there's many there's lots of money that
this Council have wasted as I'm sorry
chairman but I'm saying that as it is
and I I will not support this budget
because I don't think it goes far enough
sorry thank you councilor login
thank you chairman um just a couple of
comments really because it's a very it's
the last budget I'll be involved in as a
counselor in this Administration and um
I think it's incredibly important to to
mention this
um there's a couple of comments that
have come out I think and I'm not
political because the transformation I
wasn't about when transformation was
decided that happened like we can't you
look back over your shoulder and be
informed but you want to create a future
that you want to live into and I think
that
cutting is such a simple way of saving a
few a few pounds or some substantial
amounts of money but you've got to think
of the unintended consequences if you
look at what the directors are dealing
with after transformation with the lack
of resources the essence to be able to
fully deliver what what needs to be done
and that they're still being able to
achieve the objectives of those roles is
absolutely phenomenal so I'd be very
mindful if we just go in and we look at
cutting what pressures are going to be
put on individuals there's mental health
issues as well that can go along with
that so just to say to members past and
present and future just be really
careful and I think you said chairman
which is rather unusual for you it takes
a bottle to make a decision yeah sorry
you said it takes a lot of bottle yeah
you shouldn't be a counselor I like
bottles because I I'm very partial to
what's in them
and after being a counselor for these
years I've certainly had my fair share
but all joking aside yeah it doesn't
take bottle it takes great courage and
strength to do that but it also takes
information and be really well informed
now I don't want to see us cut to the
Bone I'd like to see when it goes
forward because this budget gives us a
statement of where we are at the moment
and what could potentially happen going
forward not what definitely will happen
so I just think we need to be very
measured in it and I agree with what
councilor siddle said
um I agree with the Norfolk Council the
fluger said but I also think we just got
a tread very very very carefully as we
go forward into the next few years and
don't just rely on Cuts because that's a
very short-term objective we know
devolutions probably come in but let's
not worry about that until it comes
let's look at how we can administer the
council properly thank you Council
um
anybody else counselor uh white as
seconder of the motion nope I was
wanting to speak sorry yes yes okay um
thank you Mr chairman um well as you all
know I'm currently the chairman of the
um Financial working group and strategy
and resources and I actually seconded
this budget because it has been fully
evidence and it has been fully worked
out the finance working group and
structuring resources have worked hard
with all officers and members to resolve
this budget and you have to remember on
this committee there are seven
Independents and four conservatives so
it's interesting that it appears to be
the independence on this committee who
don't like the budget
I've spoken to several members today
from strategy and resources and finance
working group even as late as on the
drive here
as they're asking my views on the budget
and as I said as I've thought about it
long and hard and I think this is the
best budget
now in his speech earlier councilor
siddle says all the financial woes in
over the last three years but let's
quite clear on this councilor siddle was
the chairman of strategory and resources
committee from November 2020 until May
2022 when I managed to get elected which
I'm very honored to have had the job so
we are actually picking up a lot of the
issues that were caused earlier and we
are taking them forwards this budget has
been evidenced during all these
committees
and everybody and even the dissenters
sit on this committee
I'm really disappointed that some of
these options brought forward tonight
actually I quite like some of them and
and I'm just disappointed they didn't
come through the working group and the
committee because I I suspect that
several of these could have been
Incorporated but it's too late tonight
but the only thing I will say is it's a
working budget and even before the
election who knows what the political
landscape's going to be after then we
can bring these forwards and we can
discuss them the corporate plan which
was brought forward in a matter of weeks
by Mr Leslie and the other officers
working hard with members is another
fluid plan we can add these changes in
if we think they're going to work
but let's be clear we must not be
proactual we must not have pet projects
that we fancy in our Ward what we must
do as a whole is focus on the residents
in our district we must focus on
protecting the people and supporting the
people who need protecting in our
district we must move away from being
parochial and local to just the very
small projects that really are vanity so
moving forward let's work together let's
look at these options that we have here
and let's make sure we get the best bang
for our buck and we support the
residents who need it both working and
any other residents we must support
everybody that we can thank you thank
you
um councilor fluka thank you Kevin just
on the budget now you haven't been you
haven't spoken on the budget although it
might seem so so
I'm glad you noticed that I was speaking
to an amendment earlier and and I look
forward to the corporate governance
working group listening to the tape to
try and unravel what we've actually got
which isn't very easy to work with with
regards to amendments
um I think one of the most heartening
things I've seen in Mr Leslie's report
is that uh yeah I'm not sure sure he
gives him
his own support but he does say that 34
000 pounds worth of savings are
achievable on an annual basis with
regards to the members allowances so I'd
leave all of you to think that too
that's a lot of money and when you look
at how much money we're spending or
trying to raise for the homeless and
other issues that is a lot of money it's
a huge amount of money and chairman I do
hope chairman that moving forward the
new Administration when it takes over in
May
starts by thinking about the importance
of having a a challenging and balanced
budget I know with the figures that
we're looking at that doesn't seem
possible but my question is if we never
had the reserves
how would we get to the stage where we
can afford to write off two and a half
million quid and I think also I think
going forward we need to understand what
borrowing is going to look like and how
we would fund those budget gaps but
chairman we have a budget now so I just
want to make sure South minutes I can
hear we we have a budget now chairman
that increases uh parking charges it
increases increases members allowances
German which I think costs ten thousand
pounds this year and it increases
council tax and it points towards using
2.7 million pounds from reserves in a
couple of years and I think chairman you
know I represent as you know one of the
most I'm going to struggle with the work
is it like a big Brave deprived areas in
Essex that's not my talk chairman that
is what Essex County Council have said
and you can see that if you look at the
South Minister Pavilion planning
application they say that question so
all of these costs they add up chairman
I believe that it was possible chairman
to find savings so that we could have
come we come could have saved this money
so chairman based on that
I'm sorry I I can't I I can't support
what should be a conservative budget the
leader of the conservative group has has
delivered it so I presume it is a
conservative budget although I think the
savings will officer-led and I'll always
say that so I I am sorry chairman
because of those principal increases and
the members you know and I I can have
the debate if you want at some other
time
um or even during the nighttime economy
somewhere but you know we need to look
at what we're actually doing in return
in relationship to the allowances that
we receive it has changed dramatically I
know councilor civil said I claim more
mileage than anybody else and everything
else I put in right because I lost so
much money on my car when I'm Pete pod
exchanger but chairman we need to look
at that and we need to look at where we
can make savings everywhere then I hope
that message is is carried forward to
the new Administration and
I hope I'm part of that
and if I am chairman of the first person
I'll thank is Linda Paley thank you
thank you councilor fluka any other
member I think we come sorry
I think we've come back to
um uh the leader uh to sum up if she so
wishes
oh yes chair
oh yes chairman yes I will sum up thank
you very much
um firstly I'll try and cover the
Council of civil's points but I'm sure
he may actually assist me here should I
leave any out
um hold on a minute I can't even read
five minutes later
you've been very lenient with others
chairman I would have hoped like with
councilor fluke you might give me the
same affordability of that so right
councilor siddle
um oh totally right cost of living
crisis
um and it has but obviously pressure on
us as well as an authority but I think
through my Leader's uh Speech I do hope
you can see what this Authority has done
regarding that and we've all recognized
the important thing for us all to be
doing during this time is supporting our
residents through the cost of living
crisis and that is what is most
important to them there was a survey
done of our residents and they were
asked for the top three items and indeed
cost of living uh was at the very top so
I'm glad we're able to do that
um regarding the the one Malden
partnership it was delayed by your uh
conservatives again for one year now yes
there was a delay but actually um there
were several reports on this councilor
said although I think you may recall in
fact I think
um as councilor stamp the leader then I
don't know because during this um time
of since 2019 there's been five leaders
of which I'm the fifth and
um the one more than partnership in fact
um what happened was there was not
enough detail when it first came forward
it wasn't clear on the membership who
exactly it was and the uh mou and the
terms of reference and in fact there was
concern about demo members the
Democratic accountability being on there
it did come back then at a later date
following that and it was very pleasing
to see that Not only was the leader on
there but the leader of the opposition
and I'm sure you appreciate that because
at the launch which happened in March
that enabled you to attend as well as
the leader and also councilor Stills and
councilor Thompson were allowed to be
there for the launch although they're
not members of it generally but it was
in all inclusive so I thank you for that
regarding the fact that about a year ago
Aya's leader you came to me and said I
didn't accept an offer well there was an
offer on the table from you councilor
siddle I won't go into all the detail
but there was various all I can say is
this balance going on from what I
understand in fact various people
leaving groups and in fact people
speaking to me from the independence in
fact some some people trying to come
over and indeed at that point
um what the offer was I think we made it
clear in our discussion uh going forward
as the reasons why why not and I won't
go on to another point it was about also
a particular meeting that took place
um and at that time the meeting involved
someone who's no longer on this Council
so I won't uh go any forward on that
transformation you raised
um and being about
um conservative coming moving forward
and how that hasn't really worked I
think with the transformation that was
under councilor fluka and um indeed it
sort of took off in 2019 I recall
committees actually for coming forward
the changes in committees in October
2019 and what happened there was then we
had covid strike in March 2020 and had
total shutdown so I just raised those
points there
um regarding the district recognizing
things and the administration of this
Council I would hope my speech did
actually cover off several items we've
got councilor Durham talking about cuts
and everything I think I referred to
savings but also when I sat down and
made clear I hope was the foundations
that are going forward in terms of all
those plans commercial strategy we've
got events and concessions we've got our
corporate plan it's all very clear how
this will do and what is very clear is
going forward into the future our
priorities our corporate plan our
priorities must align our with resources
and the services and going forward we
know there's a service review undergoing
at the moment and that's being done
under the finance working group in fact
the first lot of reviews have come
forward officers still working at and
that is very instrumental going forward
for members regarding budgets in the
future with all the
exact information sorry German there's
some disturbance at the back there with
all the exact information for members to
make considered prudent decisions on
um councilor fluka
um and his um budget that he's now
withdrawn he's alternative thank you
um amendments well I call it alternative
budget because that's what it looks like
to me I'm glad um chairman that is I
need a correction for the benefit of the
tape that is out of order it's not a
budget so can you please clarify that
for the tape that was the alternative on
understood proposal it says a proposal
okay but it was I I did not take it as
an amendment Council of Luca I made it
quite clear yes I could have only
delivered it as Amendment because Mr
quelch will confirm that under that
particular part of rule whatever it is
was Mr Leslie alluded to I can only
bring forward an amendment thank you no
it's that's not what it says uh leader
who
so I'm hoping the chairman might afford
me the same defense in the chamber and
he normally does so what I'd like to say
is actually for me Mr Leslie summed it
up there cannot be given Assurance to
all of these figures in here and indeed
we've heard some may not even be legal
so that in itself a concern although I
hear what's been said going forward
regarding councilor Wright the chairman
of SNR and also the chairman of the
finance working group
um I agree with most things that
councilor white said we are here for our
residents we're not here for us we are
here to represent our residents and we
have to do the best for our residents
that we are and the budget I put tonight
I hope assured you that is the case it
was a Collegiate budget in fact it was
Independence and conservatives as I
pointed out and members on the
non-aligned on there and I think that
was a councilor stamp I can recall
certainly been up and Council of Luke
himself and points have been made there
what I would like to say regarding
savings coming forward what I can tell
you is almost all the savings from
officers were operational they were
operational saves as requested by
members let me make that clear and
sorry point of order where's the
closest
chairman can I have Clarity
um the leaders just said something about
myself and counselor fluka and I'd like
cows in what she was referring to
because and also is is this a Leader's
speech are we talking about a budget
because I'm actually lost I'm having to
ask
because this time I'm having to answer
the points made I made the I I was well
I can do it but my right to do so
because obviously for five minutes yeah
please please
it please move on well chairman I will
and I make those points to me what is
important is our residents they showed
through the survey what's important to
them we have made savings but what we're
assuring through this budget tonight is
we're keeping services for that are
important to our residents important
that we support and guide them through
this crisis and going forward yes there
will be difficult decisions to make but
it's also imperative that this Council
has the proper informed information for
members to consider going forward in
terms of impacts and risks and they're
clear and I did mention about
Outsourcing and shared services and
other aspects will have to come into the
equation chairman I'll close it there
thank you very much right members now we
come to the vote and I forgot
to mention the local government Finance
act 1992 section 106.
um yeah
um
the date debate has finished but can we
have
I'm just reading this out
uh
um
will any member affected by section 106
please note that any declaration to that
effect should be made on the
commencement of the meeting immediately
on our arrival if this is later under
section 106 a member who does not pay an
amount due in respect of their council
tax for at least two months after it
becomes payable it's scheduled is
precluded from voting on any matters
affecting the level of council tax or
the arrangements for administering the
council tax the memory is however
entitled to to vote and then I believe
that goes on then to say a recorded vote
will be required by law so you you
needn't move that
those four uh say agree and those
against against and of staying
this is for all the recommendations
yes
Transformers video four
cancer Brian Bill four
casabelle against
four
council Mrs China
fourth
Zurich
stain
four
cancer
against
Council heard four
okay
against
four
cancer health
or
[Music]
please Tara
four
expensively four
that's the stem
against
four
Chancellor stilts four
cancer Swain for
council Mrs Thompson four
Council of white four
General results
four again
interstation thank you
um that then is uh uh resolved
um and thank you members um a very
Lively debate I think
uh and now I intend to move a gender
item 15
um at um chairman point of order so just
as a point of clarity man and I'm I'm
still well there's a point of order or a
point of clarity what point of order
chairman um
in relation to what was said earlier and
I think we should clarify this I know
you're unhappy but under wall one which
which I'll speak to 13B of the
councilman committee procedure rules
that speak specifically to no
alternative proposal or Amendment and I
made it absolutely clear chairman that
this was Amendment and nothing else so I
think Japan
to myself she should apologize to myself
and counselor Council of Luca I read any
proposal as an emotion because emotion
is a proposal
Mr quelch
um as you rightly pointed out chairman
um sub Rule 13 little B talks about
um
in the budget meeting no alternative
proposal or amendment to that being
recommended and then it goes through the
process that needs to be followed which
I think we all agree on and has been
followed
uh by councilor fluka
um but it does say no alternative
proposal or amendment in other words you
can have a alternative proposal or you
can have an amendment as I understand it
chairman uh chairman has ruled that what
was being put forward is an alternative
proposal not an amendment so so so
my understanding as monitoring officer
is that the chairman has Liberty to
determine as the person presiding out at
the council meeting whether this is an
alternative proposal or whether it is an
amendment and I understand that the
chairman is so ruled yes thank you
chairman I really am getting concerned
about what's going on chairman because
on the 13th of February I wrote in a
monitoring officer and he acknowledged
my uh email where I clearly speak to an
amendment so I think the point of order
and it's been uh responded to please sit
down
I now move agenda item 15 up to uh to be
the next item
um a leader would you like to put this
paper please
well chairman um this is a report in the
nickel and one point one describes about
at the studying resources a committee
what occurred on the 26th of January and
the motion uh coming forward tonight
regarding the corporate plan covers that
and the recommendations there too
chairman little one and little two that
members approve the corporate plan
2023-2027 attached to appendix one but
to ensure the council achieves strategy
through to delivery members also support
recommended next steps they include for
service plans
2023-24 to be approved by the corporate
leadership team end of April for a
review of key performance indicators to
take place um in in June there's the
items there chairman before you
regarding resourcing and I'm not going
to read it word by word and then the
conclusions chairman as you will recall
and I'm sure members had the opportunity
to attend to engagement sessions and a
fair number of members turned up it was
a very good presentation given by
Georgie Georgina button at that time
very clear and members had explained to
them it was also sent out to them that
presentation and of course we've got the
corporate plan tonight I think it's an
excellent document excellently executed
in fact members who attended those
sessions actually made those points as
well so I would like to thank the
officers involved in bringing this
corporate plan to this Council I'm very
proud of their work and we all should be
and I think I have to thank Paul Dodson
Richard Holmes Chris Leslie a sealed
here as well for their guidance
throughout all the matter make sure this
came forward and chairman I move those
recommendations please thank you thank
you
did you
wish to say anything on this yes I would
thank you
thank you chairman
I'm pleased to bring to council the
corporate plan for
2023-27 whilst it was envisaged that
this plan wouldn't come to council until
following the election in May it has
been brought forward by remember motion
and was able to be produced quickly
because significant work had already
been undertaken by officers
to develop the evidence base on which
the plan is built that said I would
still like to go on the record with my
thanks to all of the staff involved in
the rapid production of the plan
but particularly Mrs Georgina button who
worked extremely hard to ensure that Not
only was a robust fully evidence plan
produced so quickly but also one that is
really well presented
but he's seen through the member
briefings which the the leader referred
to the plan sets out a vision for the
district to be a sustainable Council
promoting growth and investment at every
opportunity to support our communities
through excellent partnership working
and to maintain and improve quality of
life and it also identifies six key
priorities that will be pursued to
deliver that vision
as I support in our communities
enhancing and connecting our place
helping the economy to thrive smarter
finances A Greener future and to provide
good quality services
but what's important is that the plan
also sets out our guiding principles and
key ways of working to deliver the plan
and further embeds the golden thread of
the plan for strategy through to
delivery
will evidence that we're achieving our
priorities by linking what we do through
our golden thread and performance
reporting framework this enables our
organization to take our strategy
through to delivery
our corporate plan sets out our
evidence-based priorities and our
approach to delivery
our annual service plans set out the
statutory non-statutry activities and
projects to be delivered in the report
in fiscal year
it will also set out the resources in
place to deliver the work
each month service plan highlight
reports will be submitted to the
corporate leadership team to present
progress and to set out opportunities
risks and challenges that could impact
delivery and seek decision
making and guidance
the data and progress updates
from the service plans will inform our
quarterly performance reporting and
called quarterly performance reporting
already adapts and monitors exist in a
new key performance indicators we'll
ensure all staff have objectives
smart objectives that specifically set
out their work and how these are aligned
to the priorities of the corporate plan
and again as the leader said in addition
to approving the plan members are also
asked to approve the next steps to
ensure the council achieves that
strategy through to delivery
and it's really important that those
service plans as I've outlined be
approved by the corporate leadership
team by the end of April and for a
review of the key performance indicators
to take place in June thank you chairman
um thank you Mr Golden councilor
spenceley
thank you chair
um first of all I want to Echo that I do
think and with a background in
communication that it is an absolutely
fantastic report I really do want to
commend Georgina button for her work in
producing that unlike a lot of plans it
it reads in a way that it's got very
real aims and objectives and strategies
within it but I would like to draw
everybody's attention to page 335 under
resourcing 4.3 a service by service
review is being undertaken to ensure
that finances remain stable and allows
resourcing decisions to be based on the
corporate priorities and I'll also Echo
what councilor Lagann said during the
budget that as we as we make sure
finances are stable go going forward
that we really do refer to this this
plan and I've looked at some of the
service we've used so far and I did make
that comment on a working group we do
need to make sure that we are evaluating
risks and impacts from Cuts against our
corporate plan and I think that's going
to be absolutely because if we don't do
that we won't know what we can cut and
what we can't and I think that's
absolutely critical because otherwise if
we don't do that this would just become
fine words so I just want to say that
sounds very sensible thank you chair
cancel the stamp
um yeah thank you chairman Echo George a
bit George in a button she's very
underrated excellent member of this um
organization I think she's fabulous
um I've just got an area of concern the
plan is brilliant totally agree with
councilor Spencer Lee on page 341 of the
plan it actually says how we will do
this and it says effective negotiation
and use of developer contributions now
we all know how much I bang on about
developer contributions
um but I would actually ask about how
the council's going to do that we've got
pots of money sitting that hasn't
already been spent for the current
housing that's been delivered for this
district and I would actually ask when
that's going to be delivered and also it
says what we want to achieve chairman on
page 343 attract new businesses to
locate grow and Thrive across the
district the only way we're going to do
that is if we get better Broadband
better connect better connectivity
you're never going to attract businesses
to Burnham southminster Dengue or
Bradwell because you haven't got the
infrastructure connections to be able to
do it that so chairman so I actually
agree with you but I'd like to know how
we're going to do it it's like the
leader's speech which you made uh with
the budget you know it's all very good
all these words but we aren't achieving
what we should be achieving and let's
hope that this plan it is an excellent
plan and and I could thank Mr Dodson to
delivering it Dodson for delivering it
but we actually do need to see results
German not another paper exercise that
we're not actually scrutinizing and
bringing any anything forward from it
thank you Jim anybody else councilor
lookup
yeah thank you I'm to be honest with you
I think it's a wonderfully easy document
and to to to to to understand and I
think it it certainly will support the
new cohort members who come to this
Council there was talk about delaying
this look you know in some ways I feel
slightly unease with myself in so far as
the fact that I've brought forward the
motion that accelerated this process but
I will just say this chairman when I
brought forward that motion it would it
could have been possible to have taken
that motion to the next meeting of
strategy and resources but for whatever
reason and I did ask it never happened
um and I think with the permission and
the chairman it could have done and who
knows on that day the motion could have
fallen uh but we know what happened next
and because of that six weeks were lost
in this process but I think you're
absolutely right Miss button should be
commended and her team uh for what
they've put into this chairman because I
I do think
um it is a good document and they've
achieved it quickly
um I don't think that the delivery of
this document should be looked upon as
an exception driven by a motion to
council I think moving forward we should
look upon this as the norm I think that
we should set officers challenging
timelines to deliver projects I mean I
speak briefly chairman to the local
development plan review and to the
corporate projects and we need to set
tight challenging timelines to get these
done obviously the local development
plan review there's certain statutory
elements to that but we need to set
um guidelines
um timelines there is something in this
where where I just like to give the
strategy and policy team if that's the
right way around to just a little bit of
a steer on page 347
they're talking about creating less
waste now I often think that waste often
is generated by not dividing up your
recycling properly and co-mingling now I
think no development plan team need to
take on board the fact that we need a
policy that where we've got apartment
blocks we don't co-mingle all the waste
we had a we had a a pre-app the other
day where it's quite obvious chairman 20
Apartments all of the waste from those
goes just goes into one co-mingle bin
now I know this happens in my own world
from for example Cherry Orchard which
was built in the 80s but that was the
80s you know we're now into a completely
different uh time and we should be
making sure through the local
development plan that we support these
policies moving forward thank you
chairman Council White
um thank you Mr chairman for allowing to
speak
um it now I'm the chairman of stretching
resources none of I said previously it's
it's quite a tricky um committee
um because there's lots of different
views and there's lots of experience
counselors it makes it you know quite an
involved committee but now councilor
fluka proposed bringing forwards the
corporate plan to be in place alongside
the budget
and um it was a split vote now sometimes
being chairman is a difficult job and
you have to make difficult decisions and
this was one of those and I sat there
and I thought actually we've got so many
constraints so many problems going
forwards who knows what's going to
happen
um for the next
um electorate sorry the next members
that come in
so I sat there and I thought actually I
think this is a good idea because this
will give us steer to the new members it
would be one less job for them to do
when they come into power
and it'll make it simplified so they can
concentrate on the jobs that need doing
because we all have so many jobs to do
so I actually voted in favor of this I
had the casting vote
now I had unfortunately the poor
directors they hang their heads in their
hand I got lots of gasps and groans and
I don't think I was very popular
um but anyway off we went and uh the
officers managed to deliver and what can
I say they managed it but CLT Georgina
button Paul Dodson Richard Holmes Chris
Leslie they managed a massive task and
delivered a robust plan on time they
managed to do this in a matter of weeks
so although it was difficult although
it's done it's a working
um it's a working plan it can be updated
and I'd like to commend everybody who
brought this forwards I think we did a
fantastic job and it will make the
administration easier for the next
members thank you very much
um would you like to set up leader
uh thank you very much thank you thank
you very much chairman for allowing me
to do that I think much of what has been
said
um is accurate and in fact uh
illustrates some of my views myself and
I'm very pleased that Georgina button
and her team have been actually
um praised by members in this chamber
and she is an excellent officer what I
would say about the corporate plan I
hear what the the chairman of statutory
resources so but as I said in my leader
speech there was work on going I can
tell you we I know that it's a
well-evidence plan which was very very
important because I did ask to see the
evidence and it has all been applied
appropriately so we know that is a real
secure profound document that will take
this Council forward of course an
element is very much clear it will tie
up our priorities
um going forward our services uh
Georgina button highlighted the golden
thread in presentations members and I
referred to that in my Leader's speech
also a very important part of course is
of the service review
um as well exercise which I refer to
um and going forward so the two things
together certainly will be putting this
uh Council
um going forward in the right place
um for the incoming Administration and
you heard what Mr Dodson said this plan
was going to be coming forward
um and it would have come forward to
members uh what happened was slight
change of events the engagements uh for
members was already in the Diaries and
so members would have had an input
before actually seeing the final
document but what happened was of course
the document came out and then the
engagement allowed Georgina button to
take members through that but I
wholeheartedly agree and I thank also
all the officers in this I'm very proud
of them and they should be very proud of
themselves they've done this Council and
the residents of this District very
proud thank you thank you members agree
great thank you we then go to agenda
item seven
and the first item is a overview and
scrutiny committee the gender item six
review of exclusively work plan planning
decision making and there's a
recommendation there councilor helm
thank you Mr chairman I'd like to take
advice on this because it says the
minutes have not been approved by the
committee so can I proceed with this or
not yes of course you can yes right
uh uh item six review or scrutiny work
plan plan decision making
recommendations that the council adopts
and pursues the following initiatives
review and refresh of the planning
appeals protocol
View and conclusions on members training
limited to concentrating on bespoke and
specialized training no reference
to related committee structure disease
making arrangements
and it says here review and improvements
of Officer recommendation
and that's as far as I can go Mr
chairman thank you members agree Council
confused about this channel because
recommendations microphone
hello Southwest
um chairman I'm bit confused because the
recommendations is that Council adopts
and pursues it seems quite a strange
recommendation I can sort of understand
the adopts but how do we pursue what
does that actually mean and it says
review and refresh of the plan in
appeals protocol
and I don't know I've tried to find out
what the planning appeals protocol is
and I don't know what the overview and
scrutiny committee is speaking to I mean
it might be I don't know if this came
out of a working group but if it did
maybe someone the councilman didn't
check someone maybe ask us and then it
says views and canoe conclusions on
member training limited to concentrate
on bespoke and specialized training well
I thought we've sort of done that anyway
but the one that really concerns me is
this review and Improvement of Officer
reports
so are we talking about reports that go
to planning meetings because you know I
really don't think that that should be
in there review and Improvement of
Officer reports I mean generally
speaking men
um members I don't have any problem with
the reports that go to Southeast area
planning committee I find them quite
concise I think they've got all the
detail in there if there are any
questions about any subjective matters
of planning
um I think the officers deal with those
quite succinctly and clearly but I
really don't think that that should be
in there and I think
chairman that it's not appropriate
clearly we'll tell you the answer again
well I hope so
thank you Mr chairman councilor Fluker
what did warn you
did you know
it's quite simple really some of the
reports are very Council please
some of the reports vary vastly and we
wanted to have a set process of reports
rather than some people have this and
some people have that we want to have a
standard reporting system
okay thank you thank you Council any any
councilor Lagan
and councilman so I'm going to be sure
it's um yeah I was a little bit worried
about not worried but um intrigued and
curious about the refresh of the plan
appeal was protocol so what the word
refresh actually meant and a bit like
cancer fluger although I disagree with
you I don't particularly like the
reports the way that they come but the
reports are subjective you know I think
that that should be something a piece of
whether we maybe you should look at and
how the reports are structured because
sometimes they are so big and I
completely understand as chair of the
district planning committee currently
um that without the support of Mr
Johnson and Devon last last meeting I
would have really struggled because you
needed expertise because of the level of
detail that was in there so I actually
think there is Mary in this as long as
you get clarity of what they actually
the work actually is okay Council Morgan
yes thank you Mr chairman perhaps I
could uh help out councilor fluka by
saying that it is planning reports we're
talking about and in particular the
reports on enforcement which I don't
know how other members here but the
current enforcement reports about as
intelligible as a Chinese guard record
and badly need to be uh made more
intelligible for members broken down
towards Etc so it could be more helpful
uh in support of our residents that's
basically thank you um
you can't come back cancer uh councilor
Helm would you would you like to answer
anything or do you want me to put it to
the vote
thank you Mr chairman enforcement wasn't
mentioning this at all at that time
thank you councilor spensely
okay so it was more to do with looking
at and we did speak to
um planning officers as well as
part of the working group exercise there
was a whole report that came with this
um where we looked at um for example
glossary for complex terms that people
might not understand making sure that we
didn't have abbreviations and acronyms
that weren't wanted and also sometimes
condensing some of the information and
also in the reports providing where
where it was possible possible reasons
for refusal as well as acceptance so
that
that you know where that where that was
possible there's a whole report on it
that went with this so that that's what
that's about and actually here it
doesn't make much sense because in in
the emotion is condensed
um in terms of the member training that
was something that we all felt was was
needed and it's been been discussed here
hasn't it before
um and review and refresh of the
planning appeals protocol there is
actually a planning appeals protocol
and it was about having that reviewed
and refreshed so I think that's it
really okay I'll put the record I'll put
the recommendation
uh do you agree the recommendation or
are you opposed to the recommendation
right uh then we go on to
um
snrb's uh strategy resources a gender
item
six notice the motion uh councilor white
uh thank you Mr and I'll stand for these
um this motion's already been done under
agenda item 15
um but if I may I'll move on to a gender
item 11 which is the council tax support
scheme 2324 with a recommendation and
the recommendation is little one that
the following changes the existing
schemes are approved a a cost of living
increase in line with the department for
work and pension schemes be included in
the local council tax support scheme for
2324 for pensioners only little B that
any legislative change is being
introduced to the housing benefit scheme
for 2324 are mirrored in the council's
lctf to ensure consistency it'll see
that minor technical amendments to
ensure that we're able to administer the
scheme reflecting current local and
National guidance and that we may
disregard anything determined to be a
local welfare payment from our
calculation Little D that provisioned to
award up to a 25 pounds discount to
eligible lcts recipients for 23.24 only
little two that these decisions have
been made following members careful
reading of and regard the equality
impact assessments at appendix one
little three that members note the
framework for the hardship provision at
appendix 2 and little four that the
policy documented appendix 3 be approved
chairman do you agree with those
recommendations thank you thank you
chairman okay I'll now move on to agenda
item 12 which is the council tax
discretionary discount levels
um there's a recommendation here as well
and little one that the following
changes are approved to have effect from
the first of April 24. a an empty Home
Premium of 100 is delivered on
properties empty for longer than one
year B the council tax for second homes
which are no one's sole or main
residence is increased by 100 through
the application of a premium at the
maximum permitted amount
little two that no changes are made to
the council section
13a1c discretionary reduction policy to
specifically deal with empty properties
which are being marketed for sale a
little three that these decisions are
reviewed as past the budget setting
process for 24 25 and annually
thereafter Mr chairman thank you members
agree chairman
um bearing in mind my interest at the
beginning can be made clear that I did
not vote in any way shape or form on
that item thank you Miss verbal no that
won't you
resources minutes um agenda item 13 the
pay policy statement there's a
recommendation that the pay policy
statement attached to the appendix 4 be
adopted for 2023 Mr chairman uh members
agree great okay
next one gender item 14 more than
citizens advice funding request it's
recommended that members consider
applying an inflationary increase of six
percent the advice Services contract
totaling 4 500. please note that the
following recommendations coming forward
from this committee are not for
consideration at this point as they form
part of agenda item 9 23 24 budget and
mini-term financial strategy due to be
considered this meeting which would um
capital investment strategies for 23 24
minimum Reserve statement 23 24
medium-term Financial strategy 23 24 to
25 26 we're revised 22 23 estimates the
original 2324 budget estimates and
council tax 2324 and treasury management
um which was a strategy and resources
committee 9th of February 23 which was
the continuation of the meeting held on
the 26th of January Mr chairman um the
only thing we need to consider here is
the recommendation that members consider
applying an inflation inflationary
increase of six percent to the advice
service contract totaling 4 500 Council
Fluker
to speak about cab
um chairman you know I can remember when
Mr Pickles used to come into this
chamber and we had some quite robust uh
conversations about funding for cab but
I think look I think we all recognize
what cab does and what pushes it takes
off of this Council but I would ask you
all to consider at what cost because
there is a lot of creep involved in this
now it keeps creeping up and up and up
and I sympathize that their core reason
for asking for this additional money I
think is based around inflation where we
all suffer inflation this Council
suffers inflation and we all have to you
know cut our cloth accordingly I mean
the cab I mean I I don't know if they're
talking about the running costs I think
if they are
um then as far as I understand that
apart from their light heat and gas we
may actually pay for their telephone as
well from what I heard the other day in
these offices although I stand corrected
on that and chairman they are well
funded I know that they have reserves
and I know they've got ring fenced
reserves but I I think chairman that it
comes a point where the decision really
is whether or not we take the equivalent
of one percent of our deficit out of our
our reserves and and this figure is not
included in the budget as far as I'm
aware so it would be an additional four
and a half thousand uh you know my view
is does it represent good value I look
at what the cab does and the cab
performs a very good duty but it we must
remember that their argument is always
that if we don't give them the extra
money every year or every three years
then all of the things that they do will
fall back on to Northern District
Council to do well none of the duties
that they perform are I understand for
Miss green statutory duties I mean
members will say that there's an update
gone out today from my screen to all
members which shows their accounts and
it shows everything else so they're not
actually performing statutory duties so
they're providing a service which if
needs be we wouldn't have to provide for
anyway because nothing they do statutory
so you know we've got we've got a
deficit of 420 000 pounds you know and
rather nicely this represents adding
another one percent to that
um where does this all stop my feeling
is gemina the the cab should be
encouraged to go away as they have done
in the past when Mr Pickles came here to
raise more funding from the sources they
have that have available we do have a
bank a pop-up Bank downstairs but
chairman this is not the bank of Malden
District Council we will be taking money
out of reserves in addition to 420 000
that were already taken out to to
support them I think this year chairman
I'm afraid I can't support the request
thank you
thank you um completely disagree with
everything Council fluka says I think
when you look at what Miss Green's
report put through just on the saving of
homelessness Alone 4 500 pounds or 12
pounds a day he provides excellent value
for money
um and is a terrific Service uh to the
to the district so I I would recommend
that we approve this recommendation
leader
sure thank you chairman actually at uh
strategy resources um I I did move the
recommendation that we agreed to this
inflationary rise they have actually
been invaluable to this Council and our
residents certainly through covid they
gave a great deal of assistance
regarding issues to do with housing
matters and everything I hear what
councilor fluka says but I can tell you
that if we didn't have the camp Oh I
should say citizens advice Bureau doing
what they do provide for our residents
the amount of inquiries they get and the
amount of advice they give we could find
ourselves actually receiving a lot more
than we do and I don't know about
Council fluke and other members but I
actually get from the citizens advice
Bureau something regarding my ward and
actually to me I can see the amount of
benefit they do bring not only to my
ward but if that's reflected across all
the other Awards on this Council they
are as I said earlier invaluable for
what they deliver and do and as you know
on the night of SNL initially I think
there was a request for further funny
but indeed they did prove that they do
go and forget funding and hence we were
left with the inflationary request I
think for four and a half thousand
pounds and I think that four and a half
thousand pounds will deliver great
dividends to our residents and to this
Council and I I highly recommend the
work that they do thank you
yeah thank you councilor channel has
actually just covered part of it and
those look
cab Finance has been brought up in this
chamber for the last 12 years
um we've argued it backwards and
forwards many many times
they have done absolutely fantastic work
particularly over uh the pandemic period
um members of SNR will know that when we
arrived at the meeting we were expecting
to be asked for considerably more and
when the chairman I think it was I can't
remember his name his first words were
actually members I don't need that
amount of money because we've been out
and we've got additional funding from
elsewhere which is exactly what we
advise the cab to do many many years ago
to not be solely relying on Modern
District Council for their funding so
they did what we asked and I don't think
that this additional four and a half
thousand pounds is unreasonable because
we could be sitting here looking to
agree considerably more had it not been
for their fundraising Council Stevens
thank you
chair I heard earlier on that we
shouldn't be um coming up with sort of
Village vanity projects and I would
emphasize this is for the whole District
it really is it's not for any one
individual Village a village that might
come high on a deprivation register
might benefit even more but it really is
for everybody
um and it may be that they're not
providing what we perceive to be
something that we must do as a statutory
duty but when somebody comes into the
citizens advice it might take two hours
to get to the bottom of what their
problems are two hours that one of our
officers could spend three four hours on
when they're not experienced at it
so it's not
it's not clear-cut that somebody's
requirement is this when they come in
they might just come in with a bin bag
full of problems unopened bills all
sorts our officers
can't just say I'm not dealing with that
go away if somebody if the cab weren't
there and that person would come into
our offices into the front door and just
dissolve into floods of Tears with a
load of gas bills or something what do I
do with this what do I do with these
demands
you can't just turn somebody like that
out of the door and say I don't do that
so somebody has got to do that for that
person we're not equipped we don't the
council doesn't have the knowledge the
ins and outs of what might be available
to that path excuse me available to that
person so it's only the citizens advice
who can do that there's we I don't see
any option there thank you councilor
Swain
um yes thank you chairman
um
I think from reading some of this
supplementary information that's been
put around by the screen that
um they greatly had had greatly expanded
their activity over the last year which
is one perhaps one reason why they need
some extra support but I think the key
Point here is
um we go on talk on and on about
supporting the community
um but I think there are distinct limits
to what the district council can do as
such and if we can do it indirectly
through supporting
um other voluntary activities as we are
doing here with cab then that is a very
good use of resources to do something
that we can't do in supporting the
community
thank you councilor of what uh sorry no
um members do you agree this
recommendation those in favor
those against
no right one
one half-hearted one uh okay uh Council
white yeah thank you Mr chairman
um I'm literally at the end thankfully
um okay and we've got
um at the trustee resources committee on
the 9th of February 23 which was the
continuation of the meeting held on the
26th of January on pages 61 to 96 agenda
item 16 statement of cultural
consultation the local development plan
review issues and options documents
recommended that the statement of
consultation on the Malden District
Council local development plan review
regulation 18 issues and options
document attached as appendix one be
noted Mr chairman leader thank you
chairman uh very remiss of me at
stretching resources I did when this
item came up declaring an interest as
much as to say that regarding responses
to the consultation
um but now we've got the statement of
consultation responses coming before us
that um some friends acquaintances and
indeed my partner
um did respond to him so I just wanted
that put on record thank you thank you
um
members agree the recommendation
uh well I think it's a
agenda item eight minutes meeting uh
meeting of the council
uh there's several there any questions
on any of those
great great
um then we go to a dinner item 10 which
I'm moving to tomorrow unless we get
a gender item 11 is questions in
accordance with procedure rule six three
of which notice has been given I don't
think there have been any
thank you
um a gender item 12 business rate
discretionary rate relief scheme on
pages 269 to 320 leader
uh handkerchief
yeah uh thank you own business premises
and they all pay rates
uh thank you
thank you chairman
he's coming before members to approve
obviously the discretionary non-domestic
rate or relief scheme which is at
appendix one members will note that um
under summary of issues during the
statement made by the chancellor in the
Autumn
um there's some um check measures to
support businesses from April 2023 and
the three bullet points indicate of what
those are chairman uh the appendices has
the amended policy and I do want to
point out it's for granting of the new
release in line with the published
guidance and to say these measures are
fully funded by central government and
members are asked to in particular note
the policy appendices local newspaper
relief and supporting a small business
relief and 2023 retail hospitality and
Leisure relief chairman so I I move that
recommendation that this Council the
proposed discretionary non-domestic rate
relief scheme at appendix 1 be approved
chairman thank you am I am I expecting
that a declaration of Interest here
right councilor white I think Mr I just
realized that I paid business rates in
the Northern District so I'll leave the
chamber thank you
Council Fleming I know the councilor
heard left the chamber because he owns
premises that pay business rates so just
some counselor Helm so just some clarity
from the monitoring officer do we need
to exit the chamber thank you
our listings
because it's sorry
um
as I said there's three categories isn't
there's disclosable peculiar interest
there's other registerable interests and
there's non-registerable interests so
you've got to fit yourself into one of
those three categories Mr chairman I
think I will leave the room and declare
an interest as owning business premises
well
everyone seems
[Applause]
well chairman I was just about to
actually explain I said there's three
categories I was just about to explain
that the non-domestic rates do not go
to
the owners of the the businesses they go
to the council so I can't see
immediately how there is a connection
now it could be argued
it could be argued that if you
it could be argued that if you this
particular policy will mean that people
will be able to continue to stay in
their businesses if they get relief
so I suppose that's where there may be a
connection but it's quite remote yeah
okay
um
leader do you want to say something or
um well yes because I want I want to I
want to move this record foundation and
oh well it's just it's just in response
I thought it might help counselor
Fleming
um a very learned member of this council
is not no longer here councilor Mrs pill
always had a mantra if in doubt get out
yeah
um do members agree this uh
right will somebody uh Ron can you get
them back
all right what's the next one the next
one is district and parish council
elections
um
is anybody else coming back
yes Mr chairman there's a few gone
missing further through they'll be back
in a minute
[Music]
chairman I know you've uh you've had to
mop up behind members lots of times but
can I remind everybody to leave the
facilities as they found them thank you
[Laughter]
um uh
right uh Mrs Fleming as
soon
um
I think um I think I'll uh I'll I'll
move on in her absence
um 13 district and parish council
elections
um page three two one to three two two
uh I'll go straight to Mr Dodson
thank you chairman
this paper seeks for Council to delegate
power to the council's returning officer
to make any changes to polling places
required due to unforeseen circumstances
between now and polling day on the 4th
of May and also seeks approval for two
changes that currently are known
members will recall that we used a
different poll in place for the Essex
County council elections and the police
fire and crime commissioner election as
well as the haybridge East by-election
since the school in haybridge could not
accommodate us on polling day
we approached haybridge Swift's football
club and they agreed that we could use
their Clubhouse the accommodation is
better placed in terms of location and
being able to set up two polling
stations instead of just one because of
the space no complaints were received
relating to the change of polling
station so it will be useful to to use
that again and to have the extra space
to assist with the new regular
regulations regarding the need for
voters to show ID before they can take
their ballot paper
with regard to the modern East polling
station
again for Essex County Council and
police fire and crime commissioner
election members agreed we would use the
Malden Stadium instead of the dance
studio at Blackwater Leisure Center
since the stadium had more space more
car parking and direct access whereas
the dance studio didn't
with voters having to go around the
Leisure Center to get to the polling
station at the back
member approvals sought to use the
stadium again for the same reasons
um with regard to the mainland polling
station this was designated as lawling
park hall last time
um due to Henry Samuel Hall undergoing
Renovations but members should note that
these have now been completed and the
proposal is to return to Henry Samuel
Hall as this is within the Poland
District thank you chairman thank you is
that Mr Dudson is that for to know or do
you do we have to uh approve it it needs
a proven for for the reference to the
delegation and to those two
um that are being formed
and I just actually
caution for the
for the Henry Samuel Hall that is really
difficult and a dangerous piece of road
to get in and out of there beautiful
they are renovating it um I don't know
if it's completed yet
um
I think he's right people have been
voted I think he's wrong but that's all
I'm saying
um but all I'm saying is Chairman be
aware it is a dangerous piece of road
yeah
it's a question really
um and I'm sure there's an answer
um we received information that our
pre-election period starts on the 13th
of March which is at least a week and in
some cases two weeks before other
authorities who have got elections on
the 4th of May
Mr Dodson
yes thank you chairman yes it's
purposely set on the 13th of March which
is the first day that we can go into the
pre-election period as a local Authority
but given the number of candidates
potentially potentially
um registering during that period you
know obviously it's the district council
and all of the parishes that are out for
for election I wanted to give the
officers and those candidates as much
time as possible to manage the process
thank you thank you
um thank you for sure that's quite
amusing actually because councilor stamp
has just picked up on what I picked up
on it's a very small car park and it is
a really really dangerous road and bend
coming out of the Henry Samuel Hall and
I actually preferred it when we use the
Luling Park Hall so I wondered if there
was any way we could for safety in
parking to look to moving it back or
somewhere else yeah Mr Dodson that seems
to be a very valid uh Point
um would that give you a problem I I
would like to take it away and review it
please chairman because I think the
lawling hall was outside of the um
the
um area so so we'd need to look at it to
it was by exception so that's why we did
it by exception so I'd have to look at
it again
to before making a decision
yeah thank you for the recommendation
actually gives the returning officer
that flexibility because it says you
know the council delegates authority to
turn off to decide on suitable
alternative venues should any designate
problem station be kind of available so
the recommendation as it's as it sits
does give that
um opportunity to look at Alternatives
if there's if there's issues Council
fluka thanks chairman I I I'm sorry I
should have been in touch with the
returning officer about this before but
with um with regards
um South Minster and perhaps he'll give
me a nod I presume you're going to be
using one of the facilities on King
George the Fifth playing field
as if as if you would know all of them
like that's put you on the part yup okay
can I just ask you to be mindful that
that in the past the building that
you've used won't be available I
understand that arrangements are in
place for you to use one of the
buildings down there but can you also be
mindful of the fact that there are some
proposed Road Works to be carried out
around both of the halls and and perhaps
if I can just ask you to liaise with the
Clark at South Minster Parish Council to
ensure that nothing's carried out on
pojo day thank you
uh members agree thank you
uh if we go to
14 we don't need now thanks to councilor
Ron Pratt and helping councilor Bill get
in
um so we'll go on to 16 then to business
by reason of special circumstances
considered by the chairman to be urgent
I have no such business
agenda item 17 uh I put the following
motion to resolve that under Section
counselor Helm did you want to thank you
Mr chairman this item appeared on the
website as as a normal item it was taken
down on the Friday
and then appeared on the
Monday night it's privately confidential
I was not asked my permission to do this
it was done without my authority and I
want to know why
um right thank you
Mr Dobson or Mr quilts here
there's a conduct issue it says
yeah I think it was because
um
well
respectfully gem I don't think it
requires the chairman of overview and
scrutiny's permission to deal with the
genders that is the constitutionally the
responsibility of the director
um of of performance governance and
strategy performance of governance uh
responsibility on agendas so
um it doesn't require respectfully
chairman any members uh Authority even
the chairman of a committee on that
um
there was a potential there was a
potential p and C matter and its
responsibility of officers if there is a
potential p and C matter to ensure that
is treated as such on the agenda so that
members have the opportunity before
reports go out to members of the public
or if they have gone out to to make sure
they don't continue to be made public so
that then the council can decide whether
it is a PNC item and that was a decision
here
because I understand it thank you Mr
Grouch I'll I'll then go back to uh
conclusion to resolve that under section
100a of the Local Government Act 1972
the public be excluded from the meeting
for the following item of business on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph two of part one of
schedule 12a to the ACT and this
satisfies the public interest test in
relation uh to the notice of motion
referral conduct issues
is that great
uh
can we can we put the recommendation